the Department of Justice announced
yesterday that the U.S Army's first ever
transgender officer has been indicted
for trying to provide confidential
health records to someone he believed to
be a Russian agent and today
we're just trying to make sense of the
shocking news
who could have possibly foreseen that a
severely mentally ill man might do
something unusual and disordered it just
doesn't add up
a man who thinks that he is a lady got
confused about which country he is
supposed to be serving it's a regular
man bites dog kind of story
that word service keeps coming back to
me because while now ever since the
Obama Administration
the U.S military has become a place of
entitlement for people with all sorts of
circumstances that make them less than
fit for the battlefield it was not
always that way in the way back olden
days of about a decade ago the U.S
military was an institution dedicated to
service
not to affirmative action
not to the affirmation of delusion
service
tough guys signing up to sacrifice to
protect the rest of us
now that Dynamic has flipped not just in
the military but throughout virtually
all of our institutions an inversion
that has already led to far greater
disorder than a man in address on the
civilian side of things putting the
military aside for a second on the
civilian side of things
Virgin Airlines has just made a big
announcement they've got a big dress
code change for their stewardesses and
now stewards I guess uh also in the
airline because
well it's a little confusing I guess
because now the stewards can dress like
the stewardesses and the stewardesses
can dress like the stewards virgin
announces we've changed our uniform code
to give our crew pilot and ground teams
the option to choose which of our iron
ironic iconic uniforms designed by
Vivian Westwood best represents them
that was a Freudian slip because now the
uniforms are going to be ironic rather
than iconic because the men are going to
dress like ladies and vice versa
my first reaction when hearing this
announcement
do you remember
when the service industry was about
serving customers do you remember that
that was a long time ago I I've worked
in the service industry before I've
worked in restaurants I've worked
catering I've worked at best food I've
worked and call me old-fashioned when I
was coming up in those jobs
the point was to give the customer what
the customer wanted the customer was
always right your job in the service
industry is to make the customer feel
more comfortable feel better
I do not want to see some husky deluded
man wearing a skirt on my flight I never
fly virgin anyway but if I were to fly
virgin I mean it's a completely failing
Airline this is probably some last gasp
desperate effort to save their stock but
if I did ever find myself on one of
those airplanes I would not want to see
some husky confused dude prancing around
pretending to be a chick I don't like
that as the customer now you might say
well well what about the stewardess or
Steward or I don't care my job is not to
accommodate them their job is to
accommodate me as the customer and then
when I'm working in the service industry
my job is to accommodate my customers
okay I remember I was working a catering
job many years ago and the the manager
who was running the shop he said okay I
remember guys what is this all about
what are we all doing here what's the
purpose of this job and in my mind I
thought I don't know to make a little
bit of money and then go home but no
that's that's the consequence of it sure
I guess that's that's why we wake up and
go to work to some degree we got to feed
ourselves put a roof over our head but
what is the purpose of that industry the
purpose of that industry is to serve the
customer and we've totally inverted that
now now it's all about making
the the service people feel good about
themselves and it's true in the military
too we've the military which was all
about sacrifice and you sign up and you
put yourself in danger and you don't get
paid very much and you don't get good
food and you don't get to sleep very
well and it's just hard it's a really
hard job but you do that because you are
serving the public and now what do we
hear from the military well it's my it's
my right
as a transsexual gay lesbian this that
the other thing it's my right to serve
in combat no it's not your right
the military is not about your rights at
all you sign your rights away when you
join the military at least you're
supposed to it's supposed to be about
sacrificing other people but we can't
think that way anymore
our Cult of selfishness
which you saw led by the left
but it has not exactly been resisted by
the right either the right has embraced
its own version of The Cult of
selfishness greed is good money at all
costs you know Wolf of Wall Street kind
of Iran style right-wingedness in
America it's it's just the flip side of
that kind of selfishness the
individualism the incessant focus on my
rights and entitlements it's everyone in
America has kind of bought into this but
no one's benefiting from it it hasn't
led to a flourishing country
it's just led to a selfish country where
no one's serving anybody else and then
everybody's miserable
speaking of refusing to serve
an amazing story in the Washington post
about someone who works for the
Department of Child Services
and uh he I guess I guess it's a she but
she now identifies as a he and so the
Washington Post calls her he and the
wapo says he came out as trans then
Texas had him investigate the parents of
trans kids
and this this confused lady who dresses
like a man was very upset by this
because the Texas governor came out and
said look it's it is child abuse when
parents try to convince their little
sons that their daughters and daughters
that their sons and especially when they
take them to doctors to pump them full
of hormones and chop off their body
parts it's a child abuse and it might
not even be an intentional child abuse
but it is parents can abuse their kids
without knowing it or without
necessarily Desiring to but it can
happen and so we're not going to let
that happen in Texas anymore the voters
of Texas support this initiative but
what about this lady this very confused
lady this mentally ill lady who thinks
that she's a man says well I don't want
to
I don't want to execute on that order
so she she goes she goes on a couple of
these calls and she's crying and she's
saying this is wrong this is terrible
but I have to do it but I'm sorry you're
a wonderful family that's trying to
trans all your kids but I know I'm so
sorry and then finally she quits
finally that's the happy ending to the
story she should quit
she shouldn't be in this job in the
first place
she has no right to this job she has no
right to deny the orders of her boss
ultimately her boss the governor she has
no right to deny the desires of the
people of Texas who still have to some
degree at least have have the right to
self-government
so she resigned as well she should
that is good this is political power
we should
we should pressure to resign or fire
outright
all of the bureaucrats in the public
sector and in the private sector who
don't want to carry out
who don't want to abide by the laws that
we pass as the political Community
that's a great thing that is political
power now you might say you might be a
little cautious about this and say well
gosh that sounds an awful lot like
cancel culture it does yes all cultures
Cancel as I've said for a long time all
cultures have standards and so the
question is are we going to wield
political power for bad ends like
trancing kids and abusing people and
denying the will of Voters in our sacred
democracy are we going to do that or are
we going to wield political power to
good ends like protecting kids and
saving little babies and having a good
country and protecting our country and
living in a flourishing Society what is
it are we gonna which are we gonna do
I'm for the latter call me crazy call me
a far-right radical extremist I think
that we should wield just political
power to improve things and protect good
things rather than to do the opposite
you know the rest of the show is
continuing now you do not want to miss
it because I'm about to be electrocuted
by David Cohn if you're not a member
click the link in the description and
join us we'll see you over there
[Music]
foreign